[MUSIC PLAYING]
RYAN MATSUMOTO: Welcome to
the Quick Start Tutorial
for the Data Loss
Prevention API.
In this video,
we're going to walk
through how to get started
with the DLP API, which allows
you to discover,
classify, and protect
your most sensitive data.
To start, make sure you have
a Google Cloud project set up
in the Google Cloud platform
Console with billing enabled.
You can either
create a new project
or use an existing project.
Next, enable the DLP API.
In the Navigation menu,
click on APIs and Services.
Click the Enable APIs and
Services button at the top.
Search for Data Loss Prevention
and select it from the results.
On the DLP API
page, click Enable
to enable it for the project.
Now set up a service account
for authentication purposes.
In the Navigation menu, click on
IAM and Admin Service Accounts.
Click Create Service
Account at the top.
Give your service account
a name and click Create.
Give your service account the
Role of Cloud DLP, DLP User.
Click Continue and then Done.
On the right side of your
screen, click the three dots
icon for the service
account you just created
and click Create Key.
Then click Create.
This will download a service
account key JSON file
to your computer.
From command line, set
the environment variable
GOOGLE_APPLICATION_CREDENTIALS
to point to the JSON file
you just downloaded.
Now you will download some
sample code to your computer
from command line using Git.
Once the repository
has been cloned,
navigate to nodejs-dlp/samples.
From here, install
app dependencies
by running npm install.
This will download various
packages, including the DLP
Client Library for Node.js.
Next, set the environment
variable GCLOUD_PROJECT
to your Google Cloud project ID.
Now run the code in
inspectString.js.
This code inspects
an input string
with the DLP API
for sensitive data
and logs it to our console.
For this example, the
script finds two pieces
of potentially sensitive data,
a name and an email address.
And that's it.
Make sure to check out the rest
of our DLP API documentation
to learn more about how to
discover, classify, and protect
your most sensitive data.
[MUSIC PLAYING]